muchas gracias has vivido tu vida
haciendo algo de una manera y de repente
encuentras que hay una manera mucho
mejor de hacerlo hay una investigación
de hardware que dice que a la hora de
conocer a alguien por primera vez hay
dos tipos de personas unas que hablan de
sí mismos hablan de sus propios puntos
de vista y otras que hacen muchas
preguntas con el interés de conocer a la
otra persona este tipo de personas
agrada más y conecta
preguntar es el arte que conecta sin
embargo la gran mayoría de nosotros no
hacemos preguntas porque desconocemos el
beneficio sorprendente de hacerlo
el año pasado una persona sumamente
cercana a mí estaba pasando por una
situación muy difícil y yo me acercaba a
ella y trataba de ayudarle le daba mi
opinión y le daba mi consejo y le decía
en una situación similar a la que vos
estás viviendo yo hice esto e hice lo
otro y me funcionó y ella me paraba en
seco y me decía porque estamos hablando
de lo que vos hiciste bre y eso a mí no
me sirve para nada no yo no soy vos y
vos no sos yo así es que para qué me
hablas de eso
eso a mí me hacía sentir sumamente
frustrada la verdad que yo dije ya no
voy a seguir dando consejos ya no tenía
ni idea de que seguir haciendo en esas
estaba yo cuando de repente me acordé de
una situación cuando yo tenía 13 años de
edad
a mí me estaba gustando un muchacho en
ese momento así es que yo me acerqué a
mi mamá y muy emocionada le dije mamá
vieras que me está gustando muchacho y
yo creo que yo lo estoy gustando a él
porque me dijo que seamos novios vos qué
pensás mi mamá hizo lo que cualquier
mamá amorosa hubiese hecho lo que yo
probablemente hubiese hecho mi mamá me
dio su consejo
me dijo hija vos estás joven todavía
porque no esperas un poco más hay más
tiempo que vida cuando mi mamá me dijo
eso a mí yo me desconecté completamente
y ya me quedé callada
yo estaba pensando que hubiese sido si
mi mamá en vez de haberme dado su
consejo me hubiese hecho preguntas qué
tal si ella me hubiera dicho mi amor qué
alegría qué increíble quién es este
muchacho contame quién te lo presento y
cómo se llama quién es qué es lo que a
vos te gusta de este muchacho y qué es
lo que dice el que gusta de vos con sólo
estar pensando en eso yo como que me
emocioné y conecte con mamá
yo después me puse a pensar ella me
hubiera podido decir también mi amor te
has puesto a pensar lo que sería salir
con un muchacho mayor que vos te sentir
lista te sentís preparada
yo estaba en esas cuando yo dije
a mí me está cayendo el 20 yo voy a
empezar a hacer preguntas en vez de
estar dando consejo así es que me fui a
donde esta persona empecé a hacerle
preguntas una detrás de la otra y de
repente como milagrosamente como
repentinamente esta persona empezó a
conectar empezó a hablar me empezó a
decirme de lo que estaba dentro de ella
empezó a mí literalmente casi se me cae
la mandíbula ajá en asombro fue fue
mágico de repente conectamos me di
cuenta que lo que estaba pasando ahí no
era que yo estaba enojada conmigo yo
pensé que ella estaba enojada conmigo y
que por eso ni siquiera me quería hablar
más bien me di cuenta que tenía una
situación de trabajo y por esa situación
de trabajo
ella estaba sumamente cargada ella se me
acercó y me dijo euri gracias por
hacerme preguntas
preguntas me están ayudando a mí a
entender mejor mis pensamientos tus
preguntas me están ayudando a mí a darme
cuenta que tengo opciones que tengo
soluciones que hay posibles respuestas
en esto que estoy pasando preguntar es
el arte que conecta preguntar es el arte
que conecta y por qué conecto ella
conmigo porque yo finalmente la estaba
escuchando y nos encanta ser escuchados
yo lo estaba escuchando con interés
genuino con respeto con cariño y ella se
sintió valorada y conecto conmigo
hay una premisa en todo esto y es que la
otra persona tiene sus propias
respuestas
yo no tengo las respuestas de la otra
persona como las voy a tener yo yo no
soy la otra persona yo lo único que
tengo son preguntas para mí es como una
partera quien le ayuda a una persona a
dar a luz a su hijo yo con preguntas le
ayudo a una persona a dar a luz sus
propios pensamientos y sus propios
entendimientos cuál es mi reto mi reto
es hacerme a un lado y dejar de dar los
benditos consejos y opinión
en el mes de junio estaba yendo yo en un
vuelo de quito a boston la monto al
avión y esto ya por sentarme a la par
mía hay un hombre norteamericano que
calculo tendría como unos 30 32 años el
hombre está absorto en su celular en su
tablet y yo pienso que hombre más
insoportable que antisocial es que ni
siquiera me dice buenas tardes en fin yo
me siento en eso es injusto al ratito
viene la azafata y le pregunta algo
y este hombre contesta en un español
impecable dijo sorprendida realmente lo
vuelvo a ver y le digo pero porque tu
español es tan bueno yo veo que él hace
un giro de 45 grados se sonríe conmigo y
me dice si es que yo fui misionero en la
argentina miren esta fue la primera de
una cadena de preguntas que nos llevaría
por las siguientes 3 horas a estar
conversando yo después le digo me la
curiosidad qué fue lo que te hizo ser
misionero
en estas yo noto que el hombre agarra la
tablet la apaga deja de ver la película
que estaba viendo la pone a un lado y me
empieza a contar su historia ese tipo de
preguntas me da curiosidad qué fue lo
que te le permite a la otra persona
contar su historia y nos encanta contar
nuestra historia
yo después le pregunté a él cuál fue el
mayor aprendizaje que tuviste estando
como misionero
él me empieza a contestar y de repente
yo noto que este hombre se está riendo y
yo me estoy riendo con él la
conversación está sumamente interesante
divertidísima nos estamos riendo nos
estamos carcajeando jockey se le dice
una pregunta el que la respuesta no es
un no o un sí sino que le hice una
pregunta abierta para que él pudiera
ampliar su respuesta también le hizo una
pregunta de carácter emocional que tiene
que ver con sus emociones éstas conectan
más que las preguntas racionales y él me
estuvo contando miren con este enfoque
preguntas abiertas preguntas emocionales
las que le permiten a alguien contar su
historia una cadena de preguntas pasamos
por las siguientes como les dije tres
horas conversando
este hombre me contó de sus cinco hijos
de sus anhelos como padre me contó de su
esposa me contó de la relación divina
que tiene con ella me dijo que el correr
es su deporte me habló del piano como su
hobby me contó anécdotas
de sus abuelos finalmente me dijo
mira es que yo soy ahora misionero en el
áfrica
no no me dijo yo soy ahora misiones no
el áfrica hubiera podido ser factible lo
que me dijo es cuando yo estaba de
misionero en la argentina me enamoré de
la carrera de economía aplique y la
universidad de harvard me aceptó así es
que yo ahorita estoy yendo a mi reunión
de extra dados de harvard de 10 años
mire las preguntas tienen la capacidad
de cortar de penetrar más allá de
nuestro juicio de nuestro prejuicio
realmente conocer a la persona que
tenemos enfrente yo conocí a un hombre
no antisocial ni insoportable sino un
hombre noble generoso que le encanta
compartir con su comunidad
preguntar es el arte se conecta
preguntar es el arte que conecta
hay una premisa en todo esto para mí y
es que bueno cuando yo le hice la
primera pregunta y él me contestó yo
dije ya hasta aquí podemos llegar yo de
por si yo tengo mucho que hacer lo debo
y cada cual en lo suyo pero yo me
acuerdo que yo dije no yo sigo yo le
pregunto y por qué porque para mí hay
una premisa y es que en cada una de las
personas que están a mi alrededor hay un
tesoro en esa persona y yo quiero
conocerlo así es que me dispongo con
curiosidad con preguntas con capacidad
de asombro a preguntar sigo preguntando
y de repente algo que esta persona me
dice me atrapa y conecto con él mire es
literalmente como una piedra amatista
por fuera es una piedra grande oscura
que de repente parece que no dice mucho
pero cuando uno la corta y la abre por
la mitad se encuentra un tesoro algo
morado lindo como con destellos blancos
lo mismo es
cuando conocemos a alguien y con las
personas que tenemos alrededor
al principio yo te pregunté si has
vivido tu vida haciendo algo de una
manera y de repente encuentras que hay
una mejor manera de hacerlo esta
pregunta a mí me lleva cuando yo tenía
24 años mi papá y yo nos encontramos en
el aeropuerto en viajes de negocio y no
lo sabíamos imagínense cuando lo vimos
fue como nos abrazamos nos morimos de la
risa nos encantó estamos conversando y
de repente mi papá me dice mi amor
decime una cosa
qué es lo más importante para vos si vos
pudieras hacer algo que le diera
verdadero significado a tu vida algo que
tuviese mucho propósito que sería
esta pregunta me sorprendió muchísimo
fue como que si yo hubiera estaba
esperando mis 24 años para que alguien
me la hiciera más me sorprendió lo que
yo le contesté a mi papá yo le dije para
la motivación es lo más importante para
mí motivar a los demás es lo más
importante para mí
yo no me di cuenta realmente de lo que
había pasado en ese momento sí no
este es mi papá mi guapo mi papá
falleció hace dos años y lo que pasó en
ese lugar en el aeropuerto me conecta
aún en día con él como les decía yo no
me di cuenta de lo que pasó en ese
momento sino hasta ahora en la segunda
mitad de mi vida no es hasta ahora la
segunda mitad de mi vida que logro
realmente entender el tesoro de lo que
ocurrió ahí no es sino hasta ahora en la
segunda mitad de mi vida que logro
interiorizar y vivir lo que pasó ahí
no es porque crea porque digo tanto en
la segunda mitad de mi vida no es porque
pienso que voy a vivir más de 100 años
ni siquiera tiene nada que ver con mi
edad es porque hoy yo estoy viva es
porque hoy yo tengo una nueva vida
miren el año pasado a mí me extrajeron
10 centímetros de intestino en una
segunda operación en una primera
operación de rigor me perforaron el
intestino los médicos al día de hoy no
entienden cómo es que yo estoy viva se
me hizo un pliegue en el intestino que
impidió que salieran todas las
sustancias que están allá adentro de
este lado se me hizo un coágulo que
previno una fuga masiva y mortal de
sangre los médicos me dijeron every yo
no entiendo cómo es que está viva tengo
más de 30 años de ejercer y nunca había
visto algo como esto eur y la verdad es
que estás viva me dijeron porque dios
quiere que usted viva está viva por
milagro mujer
hoy estoy viva por milagro por el
milagro de vivir y ya que estoy viva me
doy cuenta de lo que ocurrió cuando yo
tenía 24 años estaba en el aeropuerto
con mi papá lo que yo vivía y con él fue
el milagro de la conexión de conectar
con él a través de las preguntas que él
me hizo inclusive hasta el día de hoy
einstein dice que hay dos formas de
vivir la vida una como si nada es un
milagro la otra como si todo es un
milagro
hoy nos invitó a ti ya mí a vivir la
vida como si todo es un milagro y a
vivir en el milagro de la conexión
con los demás a través de las preguntas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]